I gots a paddle yep ha ha yeah yeah come
sail away come sail away come sail away
with me I spy a shirt Hey
heigh-ho heigh-ho he's off to work we go
toe to toe
Tony Sharkey's oh hello what are you
you better just be like a regular tire
yeah uh-oh the music is kicked up Wow
you want to go bruh ha that's what I
thought yeah that's right you better run
oh look it's just you and me now [ __ ]
ha ha yeah you better run or do or you
bug get back here so Jim hey I'm gonna
get you I'll get you
who's the shark now ha ha oh no no no no
aah damn it damn it damn it he sank down
to the depths I gotta go down I gotta go
down I don't know what's down but I hope
he's oh oh there is it's creepy and dark
down here
it's creepy and dark down here kids some
there we go all right I got my buddy
here you're gonna be my friend you're
gonna be my only friend in the whole
wide world
he'll okay oh no no no no no God Abba
Dabba okay where'd my raft go
where's my raft whoa whee where the
hell's my raft uh well well I don't know
where your raft went buddy annointed or
the dirt herder isn't over that way or
is it over that way
oh don't know oh good I accidentally
chop a hole in my raft when I'm swinging
for the shark that would have been
incredibly stupid
ah I'm gonna die Oh
there's my raft I see it hot just
drifted a bit ha ha ha ha
we're gonna laugh beside me because I'm
dad
oh it's sad what don't nice don't sink
my raft you flipped it your dingus oh
boy well this isn't how physics is
supposed to happen an area okay so
you're just gonna go gently in there huh
lifts you up and then throw you Oh No
nah hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to stranded
deep ok there's not too much else to do
in this game but I want to find it is
that a wreckage all right I got my raft
back I got the paddle I'm swimming to a
new Island right now and that looks like
it's a boat wreckage so if I go in there
I could find some goodies or some sharks
that are gonna eat me alive I tried to
find a shark buddy and it didn't work
out too well maybe my problem was
killing him first I don't know probably
not but I'm gonna go over here and
hopefully I can find something to get
home I gotta get back to my family my
lovely family what do we got
whoa it is dark his balls okay so I was
told that there are chests in the middle
of these wreckages like no matter what
there's always going to be something of
value in here ha ha ha ha
duct tape that sounds incredibly useful
bye knocks I knock you Lars I'm a chuny
uh I guess I can get rid of the water
bottle don't need that
drop that give me the machete and I'm
out of here I'm probably running out of
here
yeah ha ha oh yeah baby okay I was also
told that there are great white sharks
in this game and if you see one of those
it's not quite like fighting a tiger
shark they'll kill you instantly so I
probably got to be wary of that right
there's bound to be a bunch more stuff
in here somewhere unless I was the only
compartment in this whole place it might
have been if it is I'm just gonna move
on but I just want to be thorough all
right I gotta get I hear I'm getting
creeped out let's get a nighttime Oh
it's nighttime right now it's not
getting nighttime it is nighttime
give me back
the boat I can vote I can vote yeah okay
there we go I can only assume that I
avoided certain death but the hands of
sharks yeah BB beep I get it yeah
Jesus okay I found the meters for
survival so this is the stuff that's
telling me what I need I'm good on water
I just need food right now I don't know
if that means I'm almost dead on the
health meter hope not
hopefully that's actually not a bad sign
yay I officially made it to the second
island everyone's so happy for me right
oh hi oh there we go I have made fire
okay all right what these
accomplishments aren't that great if
people aren't celebrating them with me
oh uh I did not realize I could just
climb these things how I died what the
hell
you better not no no I climbed up a tree
and died this is horrible no no I lost
everything
whoa whoa whoa whoa and get in the boat
oh that is a great white oh no that
tiger shirt that looks big Alex pretty
big why are you how's that tiger Sergei
I don't put my boat yeah big dick bag
you look bigger I'm sailing on the sea
unsee
on the sea I'm as happy as can be
I think this island is a mirage it keeps
getting farther away each time I paddle
towards it oh I'm in the agony of
boredom Oh taking forever oh it's so
true to live what the [ __ ] is that
where's that what is that why is a buoy
all the way out here that means that
other people have been here someone
rescue me why is this here can I have it
can I take it can I have this why is
there a buoy out here doesn't show
anything for it
no no sharks around right no I guess
it's just literally here only as a
marker and that's a bad sound we got
what are we dealing with here an
11-footer whoa whoa holy crap you're
terrifying just you're just the case you
know I don't I don't know if he could
come up and chop me up in one bay while
I'm up here
oh here's not look happy yeah yeah I
can't believe I have to deal with all
this [ __ ]
this human dynasty hell that fish your
friends your food crap hey you guys you
did it let's give you wife a through
this buoy real quick
anyway back to whatever save it's okay
I'm out of here okay bye you know what I
did to that tiger shark oh oh oh yeah
the buoy was a bad idea
I'll chop you to freak up yeah here
that's right you run away I'm the king
of the sea here is a scary look so scary
he's so scary don't bump the buoy yeah
I'll get you do ya there's pure genuine
terror oh I know you guys want me to
jump in the water right now and I'm kind
of gearing myself to do that but you
know I don't know how my save game is
gonna be out here in the middle of the
ocean on a raft Oh yourself scare me Oh
God look at your face I had to chop you
up they're circling me I don't want
everything is telling me no no no here
we go yeah hello hi I'm here as an
ambassador from the don't you dare you
freaking [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh god it's so scary so scary
well why am i down here do I'm done I'm
done I'm done I'm done
back up in my raft where I'm safe I know
you guys want me to be eaten alive by it
Oh oh god they're bumping my boat
it's like bumper boats but with sharks
they'll kill me
it's not like bumper boats at all okay
no he didn't go away all right back in
the water
okay eat me oh yeah I don't eat me eat
me don't eat me eat me don't eat me
uh yeah I'm like an indecisive lesbian
eat me don't eat me
ha just do it already
you ain't gonna kill me I'll kill you
hello they don't seem to be doing
anything I seem to be okay so I'm just
under the assumption that they're not
gonna kill me ah what the [ __ ] oh that
was it huh you are go bruh oh come back
here okay fine whatever
fine you know I'm as amazed that
probably didn't even hurt all that bad
yeah I got barely any of my health
taking off
what's a baby's Oh bunch of babies I'll
send you down to Davy Jones locker
another day I gotta get to an island
I've been wasting too much time with you
brizz oh god that face you are ugly okay
almost there almost there almost there
hey now Hey look another wreckage did I
find the exact same island I did before
somehow magically I I wasn't even going
in the same direction hooray
I made it back to another island once
again I'm such a survivalist look at me
god damn that is pretty that is like
legitimately beautiful over there anyway
I got a bed now it's not quite the same
creature comforts as my Cabana but it'll
do for I get home so let me go raid
what's left in this ship over here and
then I'll be able to do what I need to
do what that was this what is that it's
at the ocean's butthole what is that
what is that well seriously what is that
it's not a thing what is that the moon
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hey whoa hey I
got an engine I don't know what the hell
that is or want to do but I I got one
where's my alarm going off
excuse me yes I'm good thank you I'm
gonna stay out of the water for a little
bit sit by the fire maybe enjoy a nice
cooked crab what are you curious do you
smell your brethren
get over here he decided to come take a
look no all mine get a good look at you
it really that's how the binoculars work
let me just put them up to my nose okay
I'm done with them okay so I got an
engine I don't imagine that this engine
works in any sense see ah number one of
four parts to an engine okay if you
can't fix it with duct tape you're not
using enough okay so I've got an engine
and I need more parts to be able to get
an engine I imagine I'm gonna put an
engine on my raft I can get the F out of
here I don't know if there's a way to
win this game yet but I need to find
more wreckages that's to be sure what
what what the hell is that what excuse
me oh that ain't logical at all all
right then it's raining now okay but
either way I've got a good start eater
even though I failed a few times that I
got terrified by a shark I think I'm
making good progress but I still don't
know exactly what to do so let me know
in the comments below if you want to see
another episode of this I will play it
again in case you guys wondering I will
play it again but yeah let me know so
talk to me in the comments I'll be
reading I'll be responding where I can
thanks again everybody for watching
click the annotation more videos that
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video bye
where's beat Mike getting the back in
the head with a gallon of milk
burglar normal dad's go no I know you
don't care
big stick to my body